less small community and County Donegal
is this morning attempting to comprehend
an unthinkable tragedy there's an eerie
silence people numb with shock that
something so terrible could have
happened in this part of Ireland a very
rural close-knit community let me just
tell you what's happening at this very
moment the search and Recovery operation
has continued right through the night
and is ongoing so far three people have
been confirmed dead but a number of
people remain unaccounted for and that's
why there is a very real fear here that
the number of casualties will rise in
the course of the day I spoke to the
local Bishop last night and he told me
that there was a sense of impending loss
that people know the news isn't going to
be good here this petrol station right
at the heart of the village would have
been packed yesterday afternoon at
around three o'clock when the explosion
rocked Chris lock and as you can see the
apartments are above were brought down
onto the shop below leaving a number of
people
trapped in the rubble a local residents
were attempting to remove the debris
with their bare hands when the Emergency
Services arrived and it's been an
extensive operation since then with the
Northern Ireland fire and rescue service
and the Northern Ireland Ambulance
Service crossing the border to lend
assistance to their colleagues here in
the Republic of Ireland Letterkenny
General Hospital implemented its major
incident procedure that's now been stood
down but they are treating casualties
there as the search and Recovery
operation continues here since we
arrived a short time ago I've seen a
number of people come and go from the
scene some of them in tears many of them
looking very anxious still waiting for
news of their loved ones and really not
wanting to contemplate the potential
outcome